let's hear from people in the audience
we take calls weekly via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to start today with
Daniel in rally Raleigh Raleigh what is
the right pronunciation Daniel I never
remember
it's Raleigh Raleigh welcome to the
program my friend
how are you doing Mr Pacman I'm doing
well
um so my question is what is your
opinion on the legalization slash
decriminalization of marijuana at the
federal level I am completely in favor
of uh legalization at the federal level
um the kind of follow-up question is
what do you think is needed for this to
actually happen in Congress like
obviously it wouldn't happen right now
with the split Congress but
well there's a couple of different ways
that it could happen I I actually think
more likely than just it's federally
legalized it would be it's federally
rescheduled so that it's no longer
schedule one more States continue to
legalize and then there's probably
intermediate steps I I don't actually
think the most likely outcome is just a
flat out legalization federally right
away I think there's going to be a bunch
of intermediate steps
um could you briefly explain the
intermediate steps yeah so for example
first it would be rescheduled to no
longer be schedule one more States would
legalize there would be something more
formal from the federal government that
no federal law enforcement resources
will be used to go after
um state level cannabis you know we
would have I don't know exactly every
single step but there would it would be
a sort of off ramp in my mind
all right thank you so much for your
question uh no the question was yours I
I hopefully I provided taking my
question no problem I appreciate it
thank you so much thank you uh all right
there is Daniel